c'est une première procédure judiciaire
qui en appelle certainement d'autres le
tribunal des affaires de sécurité
sociale de nantes reconnu la faute
inexcusable des chantiers de
l'atlantique dans trois dossiers de
victimes de l'amiante les indemnités
versées seront largement majorées et
cette décision fera sans nul doute
jurisprudence commentaires sébastien
leguay avec jacques devaux la faute des
chantiers de l'atlantique est
inexcusable
cette formule dur éloquente possède un
sens juridique précis les précautions
n'ont pas été prises pour protéger les
salariés d'un risque sanitaire de
l'amiante en l'occurrence michel fleury
l'un des trois plaignants sera donc
indemnisé
cet homme a perdu beaucoup de ses
capacités respiratoires pour avoir
travaillé trente neuf ans aux côtés
d'ouvriers qui isolait les tuyaux avec
de l'amiante
nous avions traitement pré de toulon
pardon que ce qu'on avait sur le dos on
est autant répondre aux peurs pollué
depuis 1972 les dépistages révèle que
1500 salariés des chantiers de
l'atlantique ont développé des maladies
liées à l'amiante
la décision du tribunal des affaires de
la sécurité sociale pourrait entraîner
de nombreuses autres procédures
lorsque l'on voit son ancien collègue
obtenir la reconnaissance de la
responsabilité de son employeur
ça vous motive à faire de même fait que
d'autres dossiers autre décision 11
victimes de la faculté de jussieu seront
également indemniser il y a un an un
jugement du tribunal de paris les priés
d'attendre peut être longtemps
aujourd'hui il gagne ton appel même si
personne n'est condamné même si le
montant des indemnisations n'est pas
encore défini à nantes comme à paris
pour les défenseurs des victimes de
l'amiante
ce sont quand même deux victoires
jumelles et symbolique
on reconnaît la responsabilité à la fois
des employeurs qu'ils soient du secteur
couvert ou du secteur public et même en
ce qui concerne jussieu ça met en cause
directement l'état aujourd'hui en france
plus de 2000 procédure d'indemnisation
sont en cours
le désamiantage de jussieu ordonné en
1996 mais guère plus rapide
les travaux sont encore loin d'être
terminé